Senpai
[Music] Please
do your best. I'm
going.
Now's the time for all the manga artists who haven't slipped up. Let's go and see them. Just being by their side
makes me happy. We're seriously dating. I
came because I felt like we were in love. Leave you guys
alone.  Because it has nothing to do with me, I'm
not a junior, I'm a
lover.I
didn't make my senior feel anxious, so
I confessed to him because I thought I'd make him happy.Tomorrow I'll
graduate from high school.The movie
Sasaki and Miya's
Graduation Edition
[Music] will be
screened at the same time.
Short story Hirano and Kakinura I
want to be with you tomorrow and the day after tomorrow